-It's time for "Tonight Show
Stocking Stuffers"!
Here we go!
-♪ It's the Tonight Show ♪
-♪ Stocking Stuffers ♪
♪ Stocking Stuffers ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm gonna need some help
on this giveaway.
She is the host of the hit show
"The Drew Barrymore Show."
Ladies and gentlemen,
Drew Barrymore!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hi, guys!
-Oh! Oh, la la!
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, look at -- oh, my.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is --
-Oh, look at everybody!
-Come on, they love you.
Drew!
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Drew, thank you so much.
-Hi!
-Thank you so much
for being here.
-Oh, you all look so lovely!
-They look good, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're happy you're here.
-Oh, I'm so happy
to see you guys.
Happy holidays!
-Happy holidays, that's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Drew, thank you for being here.
Thank you for being here.
-Of course, Jimmy.
-Yes.
We are about to give them
a stocking stuffer tonight.
-Well, I actually hope that
your stocking is very large
and capable of being stuffed
with the item that I have.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Wow!
♪♪
I-I-I understand.
That's unbelievable.
Wow.
-I'm just saying it might be
bigger than a stocking.
-Okay, all right.
Hey.
Everyone in tonight's
studio audience
is going home with this tonight.
So no need
to check under your seat.
Everyone's getting it.
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone is getting it.
-Tonight, you're all
going home with...
a new beautiful
6-quart digital air fryer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right, Jimmy and Drew!
The beautiful 6-quart
digital air fryer
by Drew Barrymore
is sold exclusively at Walmart
and combines high performance
with an elegant design
that looks beautiful
on your kitchen counter.
Back to you, Jimmy and Drew.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My thanks to Drew Barrymore!
Check your local listings for
"The Drew Barrymore Show"!
We love you, come on.
Mwah!
We'll be right back with more of
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪